I secretly love this show but this is
too much hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we will be diving into
all things Kardashian endorsed Wellness
from the latest Hulu season but first
let me tell you about my sponsor
cerebral so I've been very open about my
struggles with anxiety insomnia and
mental health and considering that at
least 50 of the general population has a
mental health condition I know that I'm
not alone I acknowledge that I have been
super privileged to be able to access
therapists and doctors and other
supporters when I need them but I know
how many of you message me to tell me
that there are just too many Financial
time and stigma related barriers to
getting the help that you need so I was
really excited when I heard about
cerebral cerebral is a mental health
service that provides access to therapy
counseling coaching and even medication
management for anxiety depression and
insomnia all for a flat monthly rate
there's also treatment for PTSD B and
bipolar disorder in some states it's
super convenient because they operate on
your schedule where you can work calls
or video visits in when it works for you
in a place where it's most private and
discreet for you you no longer have to
worry about how much travel time it
would take to get to and from your
therapist's office and they have
Specialists who work in areas like grief
stress family trauma and much more and
if you've struggled to afford mental
health care in the past cerebral Works
differently you can start cerebral with
or without insurance and without
coverage you're looking at costs three
times less than traditional therapy it's
just one flat monthly rate and a more
affordable price cerebral also has a new
app available on Google and the App
Store so you can easily message your
team from your phone and get access to
extra Care Resources so if this sounds
like it may be helpful to you or for
others in your life you can get your
first month of any cerebral plan for up
to 7 20 percent off so click the link in
my description to take the questionnaire
today and you can pause the screen or
look at the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating so as
always feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey and
if you are not already subscribed hit
that subscribe button and don't forget
to follow me over on Tick Tock and
Instagram at Abby's kitchen okay so if
you are like me and you enjoy yourself a
little Mindless reality TV then perhaps
you also recently tuned into the latest
season of the Kardashians I'm not
embarrassed to say that I would wake up
early on Thursdays just to catch the new
app as soon as it launched every week I
would wait to see what crazy family
drama would go down and while I could
talk all day about the embarrassingly
privileged skits about like grocery
shopping and cucumber cutting today
we're going to Zone own in on some of
the wellness pseudoscience that they
subscribe to and promote so let's Jump
Right In starting with Kendall's
obsession with her health I've been a
hypochondriac my whole life literally
since I couldn't remember I've been a
hypochondriac and so I am obsessed with
health right now it's like my number one
priority I'd say to the point where like
I'm like eating myself alive thinking
about my health uh that doesn't not
sound like a healthy Obsession to me
don't get me wrong health is very
important but when the preoccupation
with health consumes so much mental real
estate that makes you more anxious that
it doesn't give you control it robs you
of it and remember health is not just
the absence of physical disease but is
mental well-being as well and being a
hypochondriac is actually a
psychological disorder that often
requires therapy and sometimes
medication so I'm not sure that it's
something that celebrities should be
promoting as like a badge of discipline
postcovid sometimes you can have like
heightened cortisol I guess and we put
extra C in your IV because of the covid
and yeah okay okay I'm not trying to
discredit Kendall's doctor here as
research on post-covered symptoms and
Recovery is still in super infant stages
now the research that we do have have
seems to suggest that long covid can
impact the adrenals and actually cause
low cortisol levels and I would also
argue that her obsession with health
that eats her life is not doing her
cortisol levels any favors since we know
that stress can put a huge strain on our
hormones as for the IV vitamin therapy
we see a ton of claims suggesting that
it can Boost energy detox the body
balance hormones improve chronic medical
conditions make your skin glow lose
weight you know the whole Wellness of
bang but is IV vitamin therapy legit
well unfortunately we have very limited
research on vitamin therapy to suggest
that it does anything miraculous for
health that an oral multivitamin or
actual food can't already do the only
difference between like a oral vitamin
tablet and an IV drip is that the IV
Therapy gets into your system faster by
by bypassing the digestive tract and
going straight to your bloodstream
however the little research that we do
have suggests that any self-reported
improvements in well-being may actually
just be a very strong placebo effect for
example one study gave half their
participants a vitamin infusion and the
other half a placebo infusion and they
found that both groups felt better
afterwards compared to Baseline I get
that for someone in a financial
situation like Kendall it's probably
worth a shot literally but for most of
us the hundreds of dollars per infusion
might be harder than a pill to swallow I
see what you're doing so punny so
humorous I dying laughing now if you do
decide to try it out it's important that
your doctor does a proper work up
because if your levels are already
sufficient bypassing your body's natural
regulation system can put you at risk of
Overdose for example vitamin E and
vitamin A can be very harmful in
excessive Doses and can increase the
risk of blood thinning and liver damage
and even water-soluble vitamins which
are normally excreted in excess amounts
when they go through our digestive tract
can also do harm it's also worth noting
that getting a regular IV can also
increase the risk of blood clots and
infection in fact Kendall herself was
hospitalized in 2018 after having a bad
reaction to a Myers cocktail vitamin IV
drip which really should have been a
wellness wake-up call now as far as
covet is concerned we do have some
research to suggest that oral vitamin C
supplementation may be beneficial for
treatment but we know less about its use
in post-covered recovery obviously it's
a cost benefit analysis on whether IV
therapy is accessible to you or if oral
supplementation or food will suffice but
it's still essential that you work with
a licensed health professional to reduce
the risk of harm next let's talk talk
about Kendall's Wellness room which is
decked out in a hyperbaric oxygen
chamber and red light therapy bed all in
the name of taking good care of her body
but do you really need to spend upwards
of 100K to take good care of your body
hard pass for that but let's say you had
100K to spare would it possibly be worth
a shot well we do have some evidence for
these instruments used in some specific
unique cases for instance the hyperbaric
oxygen chamber is an evidence-based
medical treatment for delivering a high
concentration of oxygen to the body when
oxygen is either cut off limited or
needs to be heightened however the
undersea and Hyperbaric Medical Society
has identified 14 specific conditions
where a hyperbaric oxygen chamber may be
clinically indicated and they include
things like embolisms frostbites thermal
Burns diabetic wounds blood loss carbon
monoxide poisoning and if a few other
Rarities none of which is just to be
healthy or look good treatments are also
medically supervised by trained
Personnel who will carefully prescribe a
unique protocol based on the specific
condition but just like vitamins it is
also possible to get too much of a good
thing too much oxygen therapy can
increase the risk of toxicity so yeah
this is not the place to just like
casually hang out while you answer
emails and watch Netflix especially if
your body isn't in any legitimate risk
of oxygen denial as for Kendall's red
light therapy bed we actually do have
some research showing that red light
therapy may help to improve tightness
and elasticity of the skin repair sun
damage and diminish scars it's also
worth noting that red light therapy is
not a preventative treatment that will
help to ward off wrinkles and Fine Lines
not that 26 year old Kendall should be
like really stressing over that too much
your best bet for wrinkle prevent
question according to the experts is sun
protection avoiding smoking and limiting
alcohol intake which is a hell of a lot
cheaper than the eighty two thousand
dollars she likely spent on that bed now
moving on to other even more
questionable Wellness protocols we have
to talk about Courtney's fertility
Journey as an IVF Warrior myself this
one hit way too close to home let's take
a look so I'm doing this ayurvedic
cleanse right now and it's called Pancha
Karma you can't drink anything cold so
you can't eat anything cold it's for 12
days
no sex no working out it's crazy which
will get all of the toxins that are like
deep within our tissue
out of our bodies to have better quality
eggs
uh there's a lot to unpack here so the
panchakarma cleanse is rooted in
ayurvedic medicine with the intention to
detoxify the body from within by
removing waste and giving the body a
reset
reboot some versions of the cleanse are
actually really extreme and can even
include medically induced vomiting and
diarrhea and even though I fully respect
the ancient practice of ayurvedic
medicine I cannot get on board with that
corny's instructions for the cleanse
seem to focus more on abstinence from
General Life Pleasures including
caffeine alcohol sex and exercise all to
allegedly improve fertility so even
though there's no scientific evidence to
support the panchakarma cleanse for
fertility we do know that some
individual components of the cleanse may
actually be potentially beneficial for
example some research suggests that
excessive alcohol intake can negatively
impact fertility by disrupting hormonal
balance and while we do have some
research that drinking more than the
recommended four cups of coffee a day
may increase the risk of miscarriage and
that even smaller amounts may be
associated with lower birth weights we
have less concern about its use in
moderation preconception one systematic
review suggested that there was no
quality evidence to suggest that
caffeine intake increased the risk of
infertility however one major factor
that certainly does negatively impact
fertility is stress and we know that
excessive alcohol and caffeine use can
increase our cortisol levels for
habitual coffee drinkers though this
increase will naturally decline
throughout the day but as someone who
spent like all my money time energy and
Sanity just trying to conceive I fully
understand that sometimes it's worth
just taking as many precautions as you
can I don't think it's a terrible idea
to keep tabs on your alcohol and
caffeine intake in preparation to
conceive especially because you might
have to cut back if and when you do get
pregnant but other aspects of this
cleanse just do not stack up for one we
know that low to moderate intensity
exercise can actually help to lower
stress and cortisol levels and most
research suggests that moderate exercise
is actually beneficial for folks who are
trying to conceive the concern is more
about frequent vigorous activity
increase in cortisol levels which again
can make conception a bit of a strain
preparing to conceive is really no
different than any other time in life
moderation is key if exercise is helping
you relax and sleep better then it's
definitely an asset to your fertility
regimen but if it's making you
physically and emotionally burnt out
it's definitely time to pull back as for
the no sex rule we do have some evidence
showing that sperm count May improve
after a short period of abstinence but
sperm quality will typically decline
after only two days of abstinence
there's nothing that can replace quality
never settle for anything less than the
best you can do in fact one large
retrospective study specifically
suggested that patients actually not
exceed 10 days of abstinence to aim to
preserve their sperm quality and
motility so Travis's 12-day cleanse may
actually be doing more harm than good as
for the diet itself Courtney was
specifically required to cut out sugar
but this recommendation really doesn't
seem like a huge stretch for the
gluten-free Queen herself who wouldn't
even allow candy at her kids Candyland
themed party sure yeah that makes sense
I assume the suggestion is based on
Research linking excessive sugar intake
to reduce egg quality by increasing
insulin levels which may impact egg
quality over time but honestly there's
no issue here with having like a little
honey on your yogurt or brown sugar on
your oatmeal or even enjoying a little
something sweet to end the day in the
context of a balanced diet especially if
we're building these Foods into hunger
crushing combos there is really no need
to restrict an obsess don't forget
dieting also increases cortisol levels
and high cortisol levels are not good
for baby making well he told me the
thing that would help it was drinking
his like four times a week what the
actual
I didn't think I would be talking about
drinking semen here on my channel but
here we are little dollop will do you
know so I want to point out that this
recommendation is kind of at odds with
their like no sex rule but let's
entertain the idea for a hot minute and
talk nutrition stats oh Lord give me
strength so semen is mostly a
combination of sperm and water with like
Trace Amounts of nutrients enzymes and
lipids so despite what your boyfriend in
high school tried to convince you of
drinking is not a good source of protein
nor will it do anything miraculous for
health now the theory behind drinking
semen for fertility is that you're
exposing your system to paternal
antigens which may decrease the
likelihood of a strong immune response
to the fetus and thereby reduce the risk
of a pregnancy loss but again this is
just a theory which has yet to be proven
in literature there was one small study
that found that those who experienced
recurrent miscarriage were less likely
to have oral sex but I can think have a
lot of reasons for that random
Association that prove absolutely
nothing about causation like maybe the
fact that us old gals are too damn tired
and fed up to spend time giving head but
we're also the population who's most at
risk of infertility and pregnancy loss I
don't know just a thought ultimately
though if you enjoy giving your male
partner oral sex good for you good for
him and if you want to swallow you do
you well which is it baby
if any of these random fertility
suggestions give you a feeling of some
control then most of them don't do much
harm even if something doesn't have good
evidence to support it as is the case
with a lot of non-western medicinal
practices it doesn't mean that they're
dangerous or bad I fully support
different ways of knowing even if
they're not grounded in Western science
or research as long long as they don't
do harm but that's really an individual
scenario if they cause you to worry more
about everything you put in your mouth
or on your body or how you live your
normal life they are absolutely not
going to help I have to also just say
that I can't help but take some issue
with a lot of these unnecessary
restrictions placed upon women at a time
that's already a disproportionate burden
I don't want to go on a tangent but it
always feels like this is just another
way to police women's bodies especially
during a really vulnerable desperate
time of life when you're convinced that
you need a perfect clean detox diet to
get pregnant and then you need to remove
every possible risky substance that we
just lack data on during pregnancy only
to be told everything we eat or drink is
causing our breastfeeding baby harm we
are setting ourselves up for a maternal
mental health disaster and I have
experienced this firsthand honestly as
grateful as I am for my beautiful kids
the grueling expectations and pressure
that I have felt through the stages of
motherhood has literally beat me down us
moms will do anything to protect our
baby's health so I just wish that
someone with authority like a Kardashian
would highlight the need to help us look
out for our own needs too I'm sure I
could go on for days and comment on all
the Kardashian health and diet quirks
but I'm gonna wait for season three so
if you like this video be sure to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on who or what you'd like to see
me review next subscribe to the channel
and I will see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]